I was speaking with Jonathan Patios this morning cause he's staying in the same
airbnb is my wife and I,
and he suggested that I talk to you about my experiences with media over the
last year.
And I thought,
well that's a,
that's something I know about.
So it's always good when you're talking to people to talk to some talk about
something that you know about.
That's actually a really good tip for public speaking,
right?
If,
well it's really true.
You have to remember that you should know about three times as much about the
topic as,
as you need to talk about the topic and then you have places you can go and you
know,
you can wander round a little bit and be a little spontaneous.
So that's really useful.
And um,
but then I also thought that makes sense because nobody knows anything about the
situation with regards to the media now.
And so we're all feeling our way.
And so because the technological transformations are so rapid and you know
they're going to come one after the other in the next 10 years,
I don't think we can even imagine what's coming down the pipes and we're all
struggling to keep up.
And you know,
we don't even know how much of the current state of more radical political
polarization is actually a secondary consequence of technological
transformations that we don't understand.
Because I was thinking today about,
you know,
about Facebook and about Twitter and about youtube and about the idea that
people are in an echo chamber.
And I'm not really sure that's the right metaphor.
I think we might be in an amplifier rather than an echo chamber.
You know,
and I've thought for a long time that when I'm,
when I'm thinking about the effect of the individual,
I read something that Solzhenitsyn said at one point and I think he was citing
a,
an ancient Christian theologian who defined the universe has a place that's
whose circumference was nowhere and who's centered was everywhere.
And I really liked that idea.
It's,
and I think it's actually relatively true from a technical perspective,
like from a physical perspective,
but social needs and pointed out that each of us was to be regarded as a center
of the cosmos.
And that we have the power that's associated with that.
And I've thought about that a lot because there's something about it that's,
that's it's either obviously true or it's true enough so that we all acted out
when we interact with each other because we treat each other like conscious
beings who have a destiny in him,
who have choices and who make choices that are important and who make choices
that can be good or bad or even good and evil.
We all act like that.
So we,
we act that out.
And I was thinking that you can think of network models in that way.
You know,
um,
you can think of human beings as like 9 billion dots in a row and there's no
connections between the dots.
And then you're sort of like a dust mote in the wind and who the hell cares what
you think anyways,
and you don't have any impact on things.
Or you can recognize that you're at the center of a network system and that you
know,
you know a thousand people or you will in your lifetime or perhaps more than a
thousand people,
and then they know a thousand.
So you're separated by one person from 1,000,002 people from a billion.
And that's a much better way to think.
And we are seriously networked together and we're networked together more now
than we ever have been.
And so one of the things that that might mean is that the choices you make are
amplified and distributed not only far faster than they ever have been,
but with far more impact.